Hey, guys, we're shooting this extra video clip to go over using keyword planner, a Google keyword planner to set your CPC limit for your bids in the original video that you saw when we did it for whatever reason, it was showing really not a lot of great data for Bentonville, Arkansas for concrete, even though we all know that there is CPC and we can see it.
So we want to just make an extra one just to show you what you'll more likely see so you understand what to do when that is happening.
Okay, so in this example, I just did Val Dosta, Georgia tree service tree removal and tree trimming ran it and you can see here.
These are my metrics that I'm getting.
We have our three main keywords tree service tree removal and tree trimming.
We have some search term here tree service near me.
We have some search term and you can see here you have top of page bid and low range and the high range.
Okay.
And then when I go through here, I look at my CPC for my main keywords and I have 781.
I have eleven dollars that have eight forty seven.
I have five seventy five eight eight twelve eleven ninety one.
That's for land clearing.
So that may not be relevant to my my my customer or my client stump grinding is really cheap.
And tree pruning as well eight forty seven tree stump removal.
That's eight eight twelve.
So you can see most things are in that eight to nine dollar range, which isn't too bad for tree service.
Okay.
You have a few bump ups into eleven dollars.
So some of this is going to be when you have this kind of variance in your limits, you you kind of have to decide what you want to do.
And my advice is always going to be I take my my highest top of page bid on the high range.
And I bid one penny more.
Now, here I have eleven dollars and down here I have eleven ninety one.
But this is for land clearing.
And I don't really want to get into that unless I have a client that specifically wants that.
So I'm not going to use that into my factory in here.
But everything else is in this eight dollar nine dollar range, a few that are a little smaller.
And then I get to the eleven dollars for tree removal near me.
Now, again, that's a very valuable keyword.
So Google's telling you that's a premium keyword, right?
So if I was setting this up, I would set up my max CPC bid to eleven oh one.
If for some reason you said that's way too expensive for me and I'm not going to do it, that's OK.
You can see that you still have potential to win a bid here in the range.
The low range is three twenty.
The high range is eleven.
OK, I can tell you from most of my experience, you rarely see a top of page high.
The high range of the top of page bid, unless you're in a very competitive competitive niche and a competitive area.
But with that, if you wanted to take out the eleven dollar one, then I would just drop down to my next highest one,
which I think might be this tree trimming one at eight forty seven.
Let me verify that.
And that would be that.
So I would bid eight forty eight.
OK, and that would give you most of these main keywords that you want.
You may lose out on some of these premium ones right here, but you're going to be in the hunt for them.
OK, so that's how I would deal with that.
That's a common question we get.
So we want to just make this video to address it for you guys.
Thanks.